so in the reverse what can Hollywood
teach Indians oh la la because we are
learning we're like scheduling budgeting
preparing the actor the actor-director
relationship and the discipline and the
set but you can't sacrifice the core a
sense of the love for cinema that's I
always say that I would love to be in a
mature in spite of knowing the trapped
because the etymology of the word
amateur has the inbuilt word mo in it
love it's all about love and that's what
I try to do my phone I have to do this
one people like Bergman have said that
they I always believe this has been last
film and I may not do another flown
before I mean after so that's a kind of
energy that he used to put in his phone
every phone and I think I took my cue
from there it's a great word to follow
you've mentioned before that you're a
fan of Orson Welles and I know that he I
believe he had trouble finishing films
sometimes so do you feel that at no cost
something should be finished you're all
about making sure that their discipline
yeah because it's happened to me but no
fault of mine pictures have been stopped
but I went on and on and never tired and
said I never gave up and there are many
people my heroes like course over yes he
at one time tried to kill themselves but
and that is a tragedy that the film
industry shouldn't drive an artist too I
always feel that it's very important for
the industry to take care of people like
that it's no use celebrating Dalton
Trumbo after you troubled him through
his life do you think it's the film
industry or that artists expectations I
think generally the world
you celebrate something when it's too
late and when you threw in the life he
learnt the lesson of how cruel have been
after you see the the result of your
cruelty too late you should have stopped
yourself before I didn't know who this
is dalton trumbo was I just liked him
and then we went back in history and
found what kind of suffering and that he
had to go through for no fault of us but
America has changed so the world
you